Now that we have some intuition for
the Turing machine,
we turn to the task of establishing some
notation for our mathematical model.
Here, I've used a diagram to
represent the Turing machine and
its configuration.
We have the tape, the read/write head,
which is connected to the state
transition logic, and the little display
here that will indicate the halt state.
That is, the internal state of
the Turing machine when it stops.
Mathematically, a Turing machine
consists of a finite set of states Q.
Everything used to specify
a Turing machine as finite,
by the way, that's critically important.
Next, we need to specify an input
alphabet of allowed symbols.
This must not include the blank symbol,
which we will notate with this
square cut most of the time.
For some of the quizzes where we need
you to be able to type the character,
we will use B.
We can't allow the input
alphabet to blank symbol or
we wouldn't be able to tell
where the input string ended.
The whole rest of the tape where the
input string is not written, by the way,
has blanks on it.
We also define the tape
alphabet of symbols.
And that's the set of symbols
that the read/write head can use,
and this will include the blank symbol.
A Turing machine also specifies
a transition function from a state
tape symbol pair to a state
tape symbol direction triple.
This of course tells
the machine what to do.
For every possible current state and
symbol that could be read,
we have the appropriate response,
the new state to move to,
the symbol to write to the tape, you can
make this the same as the input one to
leave the tape alone, and the direction
to move the head relative to the tape.
Note that we can always move the head
to the right, but if the head is
currently over the first position of the
tape, then we can't actually move left.
When the transition function says that
the machine should move the head left,
then we just have it stay in
the same position by convention.
A Turing machine also
specifies a start state.
The machine always starts in the first
position on the tape, and in this state.
And finally, we have an accept and
a reject state.
When these are reached,
the machine halts its execution and
displays the final state.
At first,
all this notation may seem overwhelming.
It is a seven tuple after all.
Remember, however,
that all the machine ever does
is respond to the current symbol it
sees based on its current state.
Thus, it's the transition function
that is at the heart of the machine.
And most all of the important
information, like the set of states and
the tape alphabet, is implicit in it.